all right I have site control and um I
want this arm right so the guy doesn't
want me to mount so he's defending so I
use this counter but what I'm really
interested in is isolating this arm so
my me is gonna drive that arm here then
this hand captures it and I feed it he's
gonna think the figure-four so he's
defending that way go back so he thinks
figure forward and I come up to the bar
he turns his head then you have the
carotid
so back set up the mousse I'm picturing
what I want to do this counter then this
split split the leg split the arm pass
it keep the fence wound you follow it in
and you'll have the bar Hey the shoulder
I come down he defends the figure four I
come in he defends the choke so he tucks
his chin okay so I changed my attack
and I go to the wrist lock here go kill
okay
so go key all right here if these hand
rolls the other way which you can you'll
go back this way but that way anyway his
wrist goes you will have the wrist
attack so you split the arm he defends
the figure floor defense the check
you're gonna have the wrist lock okay
all right look for those things if you
can't try for the figure-four make them
defend go for the choke make them defend
then go for the wrist lock don't pick
one hide it in the others okay so
control maintenance you have to move
from volume control point to having two
control points at the same point before
you go to the next one okay so a very
simple example it's one I have this pin
there I don't take my hand off until my
foot is there to hold that in place do
you see how I'm doing that right so I
don't go here and then expect to get on
there not one control point two control
points then you can take it off same
thing goes when I go to here go back
like I'm here like this right my knee is
trapping it my shoulder my hand he can't
can't get out I'm trapping it then I
grab then this hand can come out I'm
back
same thing here don't go like this his
wrist is gonna come out come back keep
the control point right so you're trying
for this one but I'm never letting go so
if I go to a rep to free this if I go
like this
that's too much space so I'm here like
this let go I do in my body right then
the arm is controlling the head do you
see that and that can go right into
another product he's going to defend
that right well thank you
he goes right into the hormone do you
see how that's happening
so no different than when he goes to
counter the figure for bringing his arm
in and I go to here that has to high
right because then he's countering the
barn and then you're gonna expect to
come here and get that nope
here he goes to counter look where I
live in this hand do you see that
and so the gokyo is already on he'll
never know I was trying for the armbar
cuz he just goes right to the gokyo
you're opening things up they're not
going to be there and a stronger person
you won't be able to deal with okay try
it again
come on control no I got to here and we
we already know right so if I go for
figure four I come around he extends his
arm right you'll just take the armbar
sometimes when I let go of the neck
right now when he decides to pull his
arm in she's gonna pull his army so you
should be doing this when you do the
figure four and that is you're trying to
affect the scapula mechanism you're not
trying to tweak this or this so when he
does that
if you lift you're taking everything off
so consciously aim for the scapula
mechanism okay you have to do it slow
because he likely won't feel it so I'll
open it up so you can see and I'm just
aiming for the scapula mechanism it's no
different if wrote me here and I go to
here right that's the same thing watch
you have the same technique you just aim
at the scapula mechanism you're gonna
get it so let's do this let's start the
drill one right to here right everything
is tight I'll open it up for you but I'm
aiming on that scapula mechanism barely
takes anything if you're doing that if
you're just moving his arm you're not
gonna do it so take me here very slow
we'll have them then we'll do the other
drill all the way on and then you have
the additional counter they come around
and then they bring their arm in you
freed the neck hook then you'll attack
the scapula directly okay nice and slow
and tap early go